(shouting)
(upbeat music)
- Today we're playing with sex toys.
- Is that what we're
playing with, sex toys?
- I actually enjoy
certain types of sex toys.
- I recently got a new vibrator.
- You sure enough did!
- And it's great.
(laughing)
- [Zach] The I Rub My
Ducky Waterproof Massager.
- It's literally just a duck.
- But where would this even go?
- Oh, does it vibrate?
- Press here to turn me on.
Oh, yes I will!
(laughing)
- Is nothing sacred anymore?
- Okay, so the lips move.
You could put that somewhere.
- What if this gets stuck in there,
like what would you do?
- That's not a thing that happens.
It doesn't get stuck in there.
- No?
- No. I don't know?
- Would you put that in your vajeen?
(buzzing)
- Why not?
- But look at its face!
That's gonna be looking at you,
like, "I know what you're doing."
- There are different speeds?
- I'm not trying to judge,
'cause men will stick their
dick in literally anything,
but I feel like a duck
is crossing the line.
- Goodbye.
Easy Beat Egg.
- This is not a sex toy.
- Is this for your butt?
- It's a Tenga Egg, and basically
you put your dick inside of it.
- It's a dick sock.
- It's a dick sock, and they feel so good.
- Wow, it feels like heaven.
- I'm not gonna lie,
if I had a dick I would
totally fuck this egg.
I'm sorry!
- Is this uncomfortable to watch?
'Cause it's uncomfortable to do.
(squeaking)
- Oh wait, you're really doing this.
- Yeah, I'm really gonna fuck this egg
with this banana.
- These actually can take a lot.
- You ripped it!
- Oh no! I went too hard.
- Damn, girl.
- See, now I'm just jerking off a banana.
(squeaking)
- Yeah, and then see how
far you can stretch it.
- Wow, that's average, right?
- Is that what the vagina
feels like to y'all?
- I don't know, I've never put my
thing in a vagina before.
- Oh, what?
Look at that, you put it on the knee.
- Whoa!
Oh my God!
- That's so veiny!
- It does not look like that on the box!
I kinda wanna try it.
- Would you mind giving me a hand?
- Okay, I'll do that.
- Yeah, I just need to reach around.
(laughing)
- It's a dick on your knee!
- What if that's where
dicks actually were.
- There's one where the
guy's just on his knee,
and then he's just
fucking her with his knee!
- It gives a whole new
meaning to take a knee, right?
(laughing)
- But like, how would this work?
- Ho, ho, ho.
- I've been a naughty, naughty boy, Santa.
(shouting)
- Get that high kick in.
Look, it comes with a bush and everything.
- I understand strap-ons,
it's just a curious, curious location.
- So this could be a
double penetration thing.
- Gotcha.
- I would sit on it,
because some women really do like anal.
- You're knee deep, eh?
- [Zach] What the fuck
is a nipple shocker?
- [Daysha] Nipple clamps.
- Shock your lover or shock yourself.
- This excites me.
(laughing)
- People talking about
how their Samsung phones
are fucking exploding.
If I can't trust Samsung,
I certainly don't trust this guy.
- These are for the nips.
- All right, we're gonna have to
try this shit on you, bro.
- I feel like we need some mood music.
- Let's turn it on.
Can you hold my hand?
- But what if it goes through you to me?
(laughing)
- I don't feel anything.
- Oh?
- I'm scared.
(shouting)
(screaming)
- Oh, fuck!
- Should I put it up higher?
- No, lower!
- Okay.
- Lower.
(shouting)
(laughing)
- It was lightly!
- It's shocking.
- I did put it up all the way.
- I like that, but I don't know
how I would feel about that
like, on my dick or anything.
- It doesn't say anything about
putting it on your dick.
I think you just like
putting things on your dick.
- Put it on my dick!
- I'm not mad at any of these toys.
- These are fun.
- I think people who are single
maybe should explore toys more.
- You can basically put
yourself inside of anything
or put anything inside of yourself.
- That was deep.
- If you wanna fuck an egg, fuck an egg.
(laughing)
- It's whatever tickles
your pickle, literally.
- Exactly.
But especially Curly's pickle.
Like, it's all about--
- Oh my God, everything felt so good.
I'll take all that shit home.